I have been so far off with recovery
you're training to create a greater
stress on the body so the body's like I
have to adapt to that if you never give
it time to adapt then you're always
going to be in a breakdown state if
you're in a breakdown State first thing
that goes is lean mass first thing that
goes up is inflammation and oxidation we
know none of those are good and viable
for health you need recovery in order to
adapt and get fitter so if we're looking
at recovery metrics it doesn't mean
necessarily sitting on your butt and
doing nothing but it's that polarized
super low intensity work if you're doing
true high intensity and Sprint interval
you need recovery because you can't do
that every day you can't go to the gym
and be like I'm going to do this every
day your body just won't allow you and
you're going to fall into that modern
intensity tired but wired
sympathetically driven your body's going
to break down you're going to put on
belly fat you're going to go what the
hell is going on recovery is so
essential and as we get older we find we
need more recovery